they say no
[Music]
all right either right over left three
two one go I think I gonna run the deed
a boat like the door opens he just gets
shot right away we are going to take out
the archery attack hit for the first
time the park we're being joined by some
friends Ivy's gonna join us we make a
living doing weird fun things sometimes
it feels a little weird cuz I'm getting
kind of old for this but I just like
games keeps your mind plastic it's good
keeps you healthy you hear that mom
plays many video games I want really
excited really excited the fact that you
see everything including the windows is
ridiculous it's very large lens
yeah it's hard it's perfect when you
should be on camera just always an
escape Canon scoop 9.6 what people
subscribe for more jokes that
[Music]
I was a praying mantis
whoa-ohh is preying on me try to get me
you think of above the [ __ ] would all
under the praying mantis yeah here can
someone just collect them come on little
guy
all you looking around the camera all
right come on the nights of good are
going to salt the fortress of evil
[Music]
sorry where that's again I'm the one
who's doing interested that's what the
forces evil has five deadly archers who
are guarding it and it is up to us to
slay all of them and cleanse the land of
their poor ways you guys stick together
I'm going to spurt around the back to
kind of split the hub that will give you
guys heads move up and they can't cross
traitor fire
you evildoers we have come to take the
castle back they're luring us in these
devious evil dudes okay we'll just make
them use all their arrows I seized the
tower evil losses [ __ ] you evil it's so
much fun I really enjoyed winning a lot
I think that was pretty much really
funny I'll be the best part was that's
fine yeah so any moment she's gonna walk
that door for nerf gun blazing when we
are so ready Anna was over a while back
alive and out and I got hooked and she's
like listen I really want to get into VR
I was like that's pretty cool I can help
you with X I'm a huge nerd and she's
like neat how do we do this I'm like
well you got to build a PC she's like
okay let's do it
pick out all the parts of Newegg and
they have arrived so today we're going
to build a PC look at all those computer
parts more boxes in the boxes on work
alright so here we got sick mid tower
1080 a nice motherboard five terabyte
Western Digital black harddrive for
storing whatever you need to store an i7
6700 K vengeance lpx ddr4 ram 16
gigabytes 20 400 megahertz really nice
SSD and a liquid cooler but everything
you need to render as many polygons as
humanly possible as fast as possible but
start things off by peeling off the
plastic oh my god this is a big moment
[Music]
yeah it's fluff a senior whose idea was
it to proceed around here well we just
snip it metal here yeah
welcome to the problem-solving portion
of the video is this a bad idea who
knows fans gonna stick it out to here so
would you do try to trim there and yeah
so I try to cut it into this little
custom mod for the case whoo do you feel
like a god cutting metal Derek I told
you bill your computer is easy and
forgot to mention the whole part to cut
the metal so hear it well now let's get
those fans wanted
all right we did it that was hard
it's running just fine we have some
drivers to install and then you have a
vibe to buy yes I do and then I'll be
aiming all day every day thanks so much
for helping with this I apologize for
destroying your career and your social
life but at least you like this black
box comfort you on those cold dark
nights Herbert and I will have a
wonderful lasting relationship you guys
want you should check out Anna's channel
she has a lot of great shorts gets a
bunch of different cool things I'm
actually in one of them from wild back
yeah that's the company picnic yep
thanks so much for watching ourselves PC
bye-bye you can't listen oh that's my
ankle foot D on the left